how do
you get this cost way down
yeah so it's more accessible because
let's face it like some family's not
going in and spending 50 bucks on a 12
pack of bagels ah i know and see and
that's
one thing i really kind of hate about
the market and and
you know it's really kind of programmed
us in a way to think that you know a
bagel should be you know x amount right
but
but if you think about it like
there's so much cost that goes into
producing a premium product that's good
for us right and that r d and there's a
reason why these kind of large
conglomerate companies aren't making
that investment right they're trying to
push out product and and you just don't
want to incur that cost up front and you
know i think what
well not i think what we are doing is
we're saying like you know like
this is important like human health is
important you know like we want the
consumer to understand that you know
novel technology and and natural
ingredients and and you know putting
things
that are good for you and your body like
that you know it's it's expensive and
it's more expensive a lot of times than
the market dictates because the market
offers a lot of stuff that's terrible
for you and going to cause yeah and the
good news is it's bad you know you have
the same thing happened with beyond meat
they had burgers and the burgers were
16.18 and you could go to in-n-out
burger for four bucks and get a great
burger and i passed on investing on that
as a stupid decision because i just
thought nobody's gonna nobody's gonna
pay four times as much for a burger that
doesn't taste as good and it turns out
there were a large number of people who
would pay three four five times as much
to get something that was healthier and
better for the environment yeah but
they've since i think as they got to
scale have lowered it are you able to
even turn a profit
four bucks up you're not gonna be able
to be profitable at four dollars a bagel
we're not profitable right now and so i
just you know definitely want to make
that clear is we're not profitable um
but what we want to do is get this
product in front of the consumer take
the consumer on the journey with us
and
you know really get real-time feedback
and and that's the only way that people
can can start benefiting from the
product right so it's it really is
interesting like we get a lot of
feedback that you know is that question
of like uh why is this product so
expensive like you guys must be like
profiting so much from this like how
about making it more accessible we're
not right like
the fact of the matter is we're we're
early stage we're we're not profitable
um but you know we're so excited about
this because we think it's going to be a
game changer for so many people and
provide that element of
freedom um that you know we've never
really
gotten before or
you know and that's never been possible
before
we had the magic spoon team on gabby
episode 1220 and he told me they spent a
year uh doing the r d for their cereal
i'm curious how long did it take you to
develop the bagel
oh gosh well if you so i started
kind of the the r d process on my own in
terms of understanding the technology
what was happening in the market etc and
just like doing my due diligence in my
second year of business school so
if you count that you well over a year
but if you count from you know when we
actually closed our first round of
funding and started engaging with you
know the labs that we worked with and it
was a four-month push from that to
launch
four months from uh launch and so which
was a crazy crazy time yeah it it was it
was fast and it was crazy and you know i
i honestly think that a huge part of why
we were able to do that is because of
luck
um you know and you hear about the
impossible story you know pat brown
who's you know obviously such an
inspiring person um you know their first
hypothesis of how they were going to to
extract the heme for for example to
replicate that bleed of you know
traditional burger it took them nine
million dollars
right and and a year to to realize that
their hypothesis was wrong and that they
had to start from scratch so i think we
just we got so so lucky in
in just
being able to get that right the first
time and you know i really think it's
one in a million and
you know
so grateful for that because it allowed
us to get into the market right it
allowed us to put this in from the
consumer it allowed us to start putting
our stake in the ground as you know the
beyond meat of carbs um and you know
allowed us to start making impact and
feeling that
and are there competitors from the the
giant cpg companies yet are they even
looking at this the kellogg's the
pillsbury's all these giant brands
they're not even thinking about this yet
you know what no what's interesting is
we've gotten a lot of inquiries from
their investment arms and their
adventure arms i'm trying to play a part
in this early on
but you know in terms of r d it's just
the focus on
um
the focus really just isn't on
innovation right for these kind of
existing large conglomerates so it's
it's mostly on existing product
proliferation and and you know
additional development on those existing
product profiles so you know again that
kind of opened up this huge white space
for us to be able to step in and really
you know after feeling you know that
that very personal pain point of you
know why can't i just eat what i want
without guilt and feeling bad about it
um you know really opens up that white
space for us what's what are neck carbs
i know that a lot of these packaging uh
instead of saying carbs they say net
carbs i think you say net carbs how does
net carbs work and uh is that like a
little bit of funny business going on
there with the actual carb counts
definitely not funny business uh it's
it's just about how your body processes
the carbs so so for example on our on
our label we say you know we're 32 total
carbs but 27 of that 32 is fiber
got it um and so fiber isn't absorbed by
your body so the actual carb content
that's absorbed is you know the five
grams remaining
so so even though you're eating this
product that you know tastes so carb
heavy you're not actually you know
incurring that blood sugar spike that's
you know related to you know large
refined carb consumption you're not
you know um getting the the carb content
from it i feel like you're 50 being a
bagel snob uh my my assessment as a kid
from brooklyn and where you're at it's
about halfway there in terms of the
flavor the contextual
where do you assess you're at in terms
of if you were to put a bagel in front
of somebody from you know h bagel or
whoever whatever bagel you like in new
york
you know a nice buttered bagel toasted
whatever locks cream cheese and your
bagel where do you feel you are on that
journey of like sort of competing
against
you know the the most legit brooklyn
bagel
new york bagel oh gosh you gave us 50
i think 50 yeah i think you're halfway
there it's the mouth feels a little
chewy um but in a different way than a
bagel flavor's a little bit off but when
i toasted it i'll give you this when i
toasted it with butter i think it got
like maybe 60 percent
of like what of my joy in eating a bagel
which by the way
that to me was phenomenal my expectation
was because i've had some funky stuff
and you know i've had all the mock meats
and you know if you put up
the steak that i get if i'm getting you
know
kobe beef or a wagyu or a you know great
ribeye i would say like
the burgers in the steak are probably 25
percent of satisfying so i felt like 50
60 was pretty great uh for a first
iteration so where do you assess your at
and then how do you think about closing
that gap or maybe you don't even feel
there is a gap but there for me there's
definitely a gap yeah yeah um i did hurt
your feelings i'm sorry i thought i
thought that was pretty good
okay everybody let's take a moment to
talk about growth marketing and all the
tactics and hacks that are out there
with me today jake basgard he is the ceo
and founder of disruptive advertising
which you can visit at
disruptiveadvertising.com
twist so some questions for you jake
when is too early to start marketing
your cyber monday uh or your black
friday what's the right time to engage
people and how do you engage them yeah
you know that's going to depend on the
audience but that the cheapest customer
is the person that's already bought from
you before
and it's time today to start warming up
the audience that bought from you last
year
with custom audiences on social or email
it's time to get on top of those right
now and getting them warm and ready to
engage
as far as new audiences are concerned
there's a lot of opportunity to explore
new platforms outside of the traditional
google facebook
channels uh like uh instagram instagram
tick tock some of these other ones
linkedin
youtube let's get some new audiences in
place and test those out and find what's
working so that we're ready to scale
when game time comes alright that's
great advice so if you want to sign up
for a free digital marketing audit with
jake and his company disruptive
advertising just visit disruptive
advertising dot com twist and if you go
into business with disruptive you will
receive a 250 gift card and a free
friday to sunday ski trip in utah uh
we'll see you on the slopes gonna be a
great season